irène chagnon propose voyage son
passeport on nous sommes quittés la
semaine passée sur les bords du rhin à
coûterait aujourd'hui
gabrielle bertrand et jean naze nous
entraîne à la recherche d'eads à cela
moi
journal les daaf la dépouille les daaf
là n'était pas très loin en kilométrage
mai et était loin dans ce temps kenney
pour 400 km nous avons mis le plus de
trois jours par de mauvaises ou nous ont
dû marcher à pied et nous voici dans un
village daf la cdaf là sont des semi
nomade c'est à dire qu'ils construisent
des villages pour trois ou quatre ans
seulement puis ils se déplacent ils sont
éleveurs mais ils sont surtout pire à ce
sont des brigands c'est une famille oui
c'est notre guide qui nous présente sa
femme avec ses parures de mariée si sa
ceinture que gabrielle bertrand de la
tâche autour de la ceinture la taille et
ses clochettes sont en quelque sorte
l'étalon or des daf là il était du moins
avant qu'il ne connaisse le roupillon
guéna monnaie actuelle
voici une tombe qui est très curieux
c'est que les daaf les enterrent leurs
morts
disons une courte hume plus curieux
encore il relie la bouche du mort avec
la surface du sol par un bambou cru
pendant 20 jours encore il continue à
alimenter le mort nous sommes là sur
thur en marché qui se trouve au pied de
l'himalaya aux pieds du pays daf là en
quelques heures les daaf là sont venus
vendre leur bétail ou le couteau
terrible sur l'eau pauline ils sont très
craint d'ailleurs parce qu'ils sont très
querelleur et ils sortent leur coupe
coupe à la moindre querelle au moindre
mot
et ils agissent avec le coup mais
certainement une ya souvent des
histoires très grave qu'on peut
malheureusement pas réglé définitivement
toujours des soucis avec les tribus pour
le gouvernement indien ils ont un drôle
de chignon sur la tête sur le front est
c'est la coutume dans toutes ses parties
de l'himalaya il en sort elle aussi sont
bizarres sont des ânes ou des âmes en
avant-bourse bois ils ne connaissent pas
bien encore la monnaie il ya peu de
temps encore il faisait du troc
seulement avec ses copines dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure
lorsqu ils cessèrent de billets se
montrent toujours extrêmement méfiant il
est bien rare d'ailleurs qu'il donne la
somme prévue ou demander comme vous le
voyez ici
cependant le vendeur n'ose pas insisté
il épouse du couteau le couteau
sortirait certainement soulever la
moindre coût
dans ces paniers la porte des pros but
pour la pharmacopée chinoise pharmacopée
indienne du moins si par exemple un
foetus de ce chevreuil sécher apporte
également dépôt de pain gaulin des becs
de toucan chose on tue membres et semble
bien déterminé c'est terriblement
désertique ici c'est le lit d'une
rivière c'est la seule le seul chemin
qui peut nous conduire dans une autre
tribune où nous allons maintenant chez
des apps attali
si notre petit cardin en marche nos
porteurs sont partis en avant seul le
magnétophone nous suit et la caméra bien
sous c'est un village obtenu c'est le
premier village à pattani nous arrivons
les appâts thani lift encore à l'âge de
pierre ils sont très primitif
cependant ce sont d'excellents
agriculteurs bien qu'ils élèvent du béta
ils ont des boeufs et ne connaissent pas
la traction animale ou là un drôle de
narines
sellal mes petites parfait de la femme à
pattani tout jeune et ses percées
narines pour s'incruster des rondelles
de boîte et se dépêchent d'agrandir le
relais l'homme c'est difficile de savoir
lequel sa coquetterie
c'est cette ceinture de rotin tressé
qu'ils portent presque toujours
lorsqu'il va au travail il on est
solides costauds ils sont très robustes
ils ne craignent pas le froid ont fini
cette femme doit être considérée comme
extrêmement de led zep à tanis vivent
dans une société très bien organisés les
jeunes gens ils sont divisés en deux
classes esclaves et patriciens mais les
esclaves sont extrêmement bien traités
et chez les jeunes jusqu'à l'âge du
mariage
il n'y a absolument pas de différence
entre un patricien espoir
les jeunes gens rentrent une liberté
sexuelle extrêmement grande maria mais
après le mariage qui est une chose
sacrée fait la totale
mabulle terre et punis avec la plus
grande rigueur viol si un homme est pris
en flagrant délit d'adultère
l'amant il est mise à mort
il est coupé en petits morceaux et ses
morceaux sont clés aux besoins du
mariage non mais ceci ce bouillon c'est
pour la punition de la femme qui elle
doit le boire ils n'en sont pas des
goûters voyez vous il ya très peu
d'adultes en soi
rick leurs maisons sont extrêmement
précaires d'ailleurs ils ne vivent
presque jamais à l'intérieur mais
toujours sur ses plans parce que c'est
beaucoup trop sombre il n'y a qu'une
seule ouverture c'est la porte d'entrée
son un hôtel de sacrifices sur le devant
quand il sacrifie en un animal et je
dépose un homo je suis un petit bébé qui
nous avions donné un morceau de sucre ça
devait être le premier morceau de sucre
et qu'il doutait de ses amis et de la
trouvais absolument
celle ci n a pas qu'en l'énergie nous
précise qu on ne voit pas encore mais
sont certainement déjà persil et un
petit bon goût de nant la grosseur d'une
allumette
ça doit faire mal en france votre fonds
spears et bien les oreilles pour mais
d'une boucle d'oreille
ça c'est une question le mode demande
et voici une scène dépouillage c'est
tout article est absolument répugnant
c'est un geste et de la vie courante
sous pression ils sont extrêmement sale
ne se lave pas plus que les gouttes
année et vous avez dû rencontrer pas mal
de puno mi case oui mais nous ne vivions
jamais dans les cases caisses grâce au
cd oui qu'est ce que c'est si c'est un
oui c'est un espèce de thèmes qui
indique que voici la case du grand chef
et le grand chef le voici
malheureusement au garde à vous un peu
intimidés par la caméra mes enfants
assez de temps du loto
c'est plus bien voici tous les daaf la
porte un petit chapeau de rotin tressé
lorsque ces chapeaux et surmonté de
plumes ou d'un bec de tout quand cela
signifie qu'ils ont à faire un grand
chasseur aussi un chapeau différent qui
indique que celle sorcier le médecin du
mylar et je n'irai pas confus vous
confier ces mythomanes prudente oublie
certainement
ici on voit très bien la noue dans les
oreilles et c'est simplement oui
simplement un anneau de bambou et
chignon c'est une panne de bambou dossou
d'ivoire
le travail c'est un jour un tout jeune
et c'est quand même un chasseur
puisqu'il a déjà drobecq de tout quand
kelly stade du pas forcément ce lundi
qui a fait un exploit de phase iib ceci
les a pas tenues sont appelés par leurs
voisins les coupeurs demain parce que
lorsqu'un homme est puni pour une raison
quelconque pour un vol ou autre chose on
les coupe la main
généralement il est hué avant et on la
brûle sur 7 au tél
c'est définitif c'est les philippines
iranien pure et punis
ici c'est un temple à eau qui datent du
10ème siècle car nous sommes redescendus
dans la plaine maintenant et nous voici
dans les plantations t ch avec l'ugtt
est originaire de l'assam vous et sur
ses plantations de thé nous avons la
chance inouïe de rencontrer des naga qui
sont si terribles coupeur de têtes dont
on parle si souvent qui donne tant de
fil à retordre au gouvernement indien
ils sont riboud sont très beaux et sont
très musclées sont très fins sont très
robustes on est triple ils sont très
proches nous sommes déjà sur la rive-sud
et maintenant tout le monde cela est
tout à fait l'opposé bonne chose vous
pouvez vous oui parce que nous pourrons
partager leurs cannes
et vous avez vécu dans l'es15 nagas
enfin on peut pas longtemps fait les
maga mais nous avons vécu dans d'autres
tribus ceci est un chef non c'est hf
voici son bras sept commandements qui me
fait savoir à tout le monde et dans ce
game et voilà la danse derrière
s'habille spécialement comme ce sont des
chasseurs de têtes que l'on disait vous
pouvez voir dès qu ils se retourneront
on l'éloigné un peu dépassé les quatre
humains qui porte dans l'orne
d'explosion rythme s'accélère oui ces
petits tabliers blanche ont fait avec
des coquillages enfiler sur des fils de
jute et ses gros bracelets sont venues
seules pièces d'ivoire
il porte des plumes de tout temps sur la
tête
sont capables de courir dans les heures
et des heures dans la jungle piste d'un
jubilé avec la sport à la lance le super
et même conseil soutient la durée
effective sont éliminés dès la plus
tendre enfance
merci jean nazet et à la semaine
prochaine pour prendre contact avec les
garrots irène chagnaud vous a proposé
voyage sans passeport cette émission a
été réalisée avec le concours de
gabrielle bertrand jean naze solange
péters montage claude un char son ami
cuvée d'illustration sonore denise
glaser